Bruselas sigue adelante y la comisión
europea ha propuesto un paquete de ayuda
de 18.000 millones de euros a Ucrania ya
para el próximo año el objetivo es poder
ayudar al país en sus pagos más
inmediatos con unas necesidades de
aproximadamente unos 4.000 millones de
euros al mes el dinero Se enviará a
través de préstamos en que los intereses
estarán cubiertos por los propios
estados miembros este dinero se podrá
enviar a Ucrania gracias a la emisión de
deuda conjunta europea en que la Unión
Europea tendrá que acudir a los mercados
para poder ayudar a Ucrania el objetivo
de la comisión europea Es que este nuevo
paquete de ayuda se puede aprobar antes
de finalizar el año porque las urgencias
de Ucrania son inmediatas de hecho el
primer desembolso se espera que pueda
ser ya para el próximo mes de enero este
dinero eso sí está sujeta condiciones
Ucrania tendrá que aprobar también
reformas en el estado de derecho también
en la lucha contra el fraude y contra la
corrupción medidas que en cualquier caso
tiene que aplicar a pesar de estar en
guerra también por ser país candidato a
entrar dentro de la Unión Europea Eso sí
aún hay dudas que se va a poder
aprobarse este plan de ayuda porque
Hungría ya amenazado con vetar esta
nueva ayuda a Ucrania para presionar a
la Unión Europea aún así la comisión
europea segura que está dispuesta a
negociar con Hungría y Espera que puedan
limarse las asperezas y aprobar este
paquete